[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I'm joined by Marlon Wayans and
Priya Ferguson the stars of the curse of
Bridge Hall which is on Netflix Friday
how you guys doing today I'm good I mean
I'm just excited somebody's excited to
talk to us because yeah mine nobody been
excited to talk to me since my mama died
excited to talk to me so dude I'm I'm so
excited I woke up this morning I was
just pumped to talk to Marlon Wayans and
Marlon it's interesting too we don't get
to see your character dress up here in
this film but do you have any costumes
you've loved dressing up as before for
Halloween yes I dress up as Run DMC
every year because all I do is put on a
dope ass tracksuit and some gazelle
Shades and I'm hip I'm hot and I'm dope
and some Adidas and I'm good I still
look good you know what I'm saying you
ain't gotta do too much you know what I
mean Run DMC every year me and my nephew
Craig and my nephew Damien we always Run
DMC yeah I love that yeah keep it simple
perfect and then Priya you got this
iconic look going with the purple witch
costume in the film did you choose that
costume or was it always going to be a
witch I did not choose that costume that
was um production then was I when I saw
it and I saw like the sketch of
everything and I went to my first
fitting I was like oh yeah this is gonna
be cute and then I had to wear that put
that damn
that hat was in everybody's shot it was
sent away stunts everybody yeah lighting
can we move your head
yeah the Hat was it was cute for the
first day once I started I was just like
all right y'all this is no yeah thank
you not many people could wear that hat
yeah but you didn't just no you totally
rock it and it's totally worth it it
came out awesome and Marlon we see your
character running around you know sets
that looked like haunted mazes are you
someone willing to do haunted maze or a
haunted house in real life or you you
have no bid for that I've done them and
I walk around and they start with that
stuff and my my business just goes up
like y'all keep it moving bro keep keep
it moving I know your job is to scare me
but I'm just scared my naturally
reaction it don't make me Will Smith you
just don't own what you felt I love that
man I love the slapstick you do in this
film so I think people should get
excited to see that
with them
yeah and Priya you have such a
commanding screen presence in anything
you do is that something you feel like
you just tap into naturally like it's
inside of you or it's something that you
kind of have to always really prep for I
mean
I do prep myself for any role I kind of
do just to get some background
information on what the air is what it's
about all that stuff but I think I think
it's just naturally a gift for me it
comes easy for me I don't have to really
do too much to kind of tap into a role
so
yeah no it's it's great and that's it's
just like a total natural yeah
Marlon man some people just have it she
got it definitely
um I totally agree that Marlon was there
anything in this film you were most
proud of doing or pulling off
um I think I'm most proud of um
I think the balance in the movie you
know
um that there's really good special
effects that there's really good humor
uh there's a difference between hilarity
and humor I think this one has a lot of
humor which is consistent and you just
feel good at the end of the movie and to
put together a family friendly horror
comedy which is something I'm completely
foreign too because scary movie we had
all kind of liquids and fluids and
buttocks and body parts and you know
haunted house I was humping everything
that a dog stuffed animals
hear the people it was so it was good to
do something that was just something
that my kid could actually want
yeah totally and you just gave both of
you a great interview so thank you for
that everyone check Marlin and Priya
just absolutely kill it in the curse of
bridge Hollow on Netflix Friday thank
you guys so much for joining me and I'll
talk to you in the future thank you